Hãy hai tháng mười bảo tăng lúc, hợp tại Trung Tâm Paris tụi đồ nước pháp đã mở cửa trở lại đón dù khách sau bá ngày phải đón kửa vì vụ trộ các món trang sức khoảng giá về trình đốc.
Truy nhiên theo thông bảo của bảo tăng, khu trưng bầy cari đi Apple Lo, nơi sẻ giá của trộm hôm mì chính tháng mười vẫn tiếp tục bị phong toạ.
Sau khi bảo tăng bở cửa trở lại, tổng thương pháp em anh lên mặc lông đã yêu cầu để nhăng việc tăng cường an đình tại Luph Hơ.
Hện các nhà được chắc pháp đang cình xung truy tìm chưởng tên trộn đã tổ thoát cũng bộ sự tập trang sức khoảng giá có giả trị ước tình tạng đạng triệu RO, khoảng 1,5 %, 1,5 lần lỗi vụ pháp lo khong nơi nề cho biết đã có hơn 1 chắc nhà được chá được huy động tham gia của chuy tìm các nhi pháp.
và ông tin tưởng chắc sản sẽ mắt được tụ pháp.
Theo rồi quan sát, sau những bằng đầu bị đen cấp quả nổi tiếng,
nên việc bản chung với mấy trạng là rất khó khi không ai giám mua.
Sao đò những viết kiên cộng và ngọt rất có thể sẽ bị thảo rồi,
và bắn thành tưởng bằng hàng dừng lệ, như vậy sẽ rất khó có thể nhận dịt đó là những bằng đầu đã bị đen cấp.
Nếu điều này sẽ ra, những bằng trong suất hoàng ra này sẽ bị nất mạnh mại.